[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute sprit kuchen
weil ihr euch das gewünscht habe daher
immer wieder gerne kommentieren was ich
als nächstes wünschen
ich mache das immer so ein bisschen von
euch abhängig was ihr euch wünscht und
das gute ist ich persönlich mag sprits
kuchen auch total gerne und daher zeige
ich euch jetzt die zutaten für unseren
brandtag ich stehe nämlich hier unten
wir benötigen einmal wasser zucker und
salz mehl eier und butter und ich
persönlich habe die zutat noch immer
daheim und daher gehe ich jetzt direkt
rüber zum herd und wir fangen direkt an
mit dem brand ein
jetzt wird zuallererst wasser butter
salz und zucker im topf ein mal
aufgekocht und dann zeige ich euch was
ihr mit dem machen die eier erstmal
nicht beachten sie bleiben erst mal an
der seite das futter wasser gemisch das
köchelt jetzt und ich gehe auf stufe
sieben von neun uhr für euch eine
richtlinie und gäbe dass mir jetzt in
einem schwung mit dazu und dann müsst
ihr mit eurem kochlöffel arbeiten
wir brennen das ganze nämlich ab am kopf
und da zeige ich euch gleich was am
topfboden entsteht nämlich so eine weiße
kruste da braucht euch auch keine sorgen
machen die geht auch ganz einfach wieder
ab jetzt habe ich dem teig abgebrannt
und es macht ihr immer in
fortschreitenden bewegungen also nicht
mal auf einer stelle stehen lassen
sondern immer weiter bewegen und das
hier löst sich gleich wie gesagt wie von
allein das heißt ihr müsst den top nicht
wegwerfen und es gebe ich jetzt hier
direkt in eine rührschüssel verteilt
dass so ein bisschen und lasst es
abkühlen
15 minuten später also der teig ist
jetzt natürlich ganz ausgekühlt das soll
er auch gar nicht sonst wird es
schwierig die eier zu verarbeiten aber
jetzt nach 15 minuten ist es nur noch
lauwarm
das heißt die eier werden nicht gleich
zurück ich mache jetzt die
küchenmaschine an also ich schmeiße an
auf niedriger stufe
ihr könnt aber auch euer handgerät
verwenden ihr könntet auch einfach nur
eure hände benutzen aber glaubt mir habt
danach solche arten also mit am besten
irgendeine maschine irgendein gerät und
dann die eier nacheinander einrühren
[Musik]
sie bricht liebl klebrige angelegenheit
und auch sehr zäh aber das ist so also
das ergebnis des hauptsache super lecker
und ich zeige euch jetzt ihr was ich
kurz vorbereite nämlich einen
spritzbeutel die sally ist extrem robust
ich finde man dass das non plus ultra
wenn ein spritzbeutel wie dieser einfach
mal den brand tag über steht oben auf zu
platzen
sind das also unser kriterium ist im job
aufzunehmen und da wäre ich jetzt eine
tolle reihen die verlinke ich euch auch
unten in der box und das bin ich jetzt
einfach rein stellt vor allem die spitze
auf und dann ist es eigentlich so weit
schon vorbereitet ich glaube ich schon
über die spiel sofort auch schon
zufrieden
meinst du irgendwann bekommt man ein
gefühl dafür und jetzt habe ich noch was
vorbereitet das ist auch super hilfreich
weil wir haben gleich das frittierfett
es wird er gleich kritisiert und um das
ihn wieder rein zu befördern
brauchen wir das papier das habe ich mir
jetzt ganz einfach zurecht geschnitten
und da gibt jetzt etwas zeit drauf ich
kann das immer am besten dosieren mit
back transpower aus der dose ich weiß es
hat nicht jeder nennt einfach fällt mit
pinsel aber dann habt ihr halt die
gefahr dass es zu viel ist ein bisschen
hier auf die arbeitsfläche damit das
klebt impression aufspritzen können und
ganz leicht die oberfläche benetzen
jetzt völlig kurz meint ein mann geht es
weiter
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich meinen sprits kuchen
aufgespritzt ich mache mal gerne zwei
rein weil ich mag es nicht wenn die so
flach sind der bäckerei sind ja auch
immer so schön hoch und ich bin ja immer
für mehr realität mehr realität auf
instagram das wissen alle die uns auf
instagram folgen und aber auch mehr
realität auf youtube in das gerade
bestimmten locker sie aus haben nämlich
aufgenommen und so wie das in echt
auswendig hier den tag auch spritze
achtung
mein gott ich hab's geschafft
hier kannst du gerne machen
komm rüber also so ist es ist halt ein
bisschen anstrengend aber es lohnt sich
man fett ist sobald das erkennt ihr
daran nicht nur mir sondern schafft
league spiels gibt es einmal rein und da
steigen die blasen auf ist es auch
wichtig wie schnell die blasen
aufsteigen nicht geht es hier sogar
unter auf stufe 6 von 9
denn es ist wichtig dass das fett nicht
zu heiß ist aber auch nicht zu kalt
damit sich der teig nicht aufsaugt mit
fett sondern wirklich schön kross und
knusprig wird und dann nehme ich jetzt
meinen bringen und dadurch dass wir das
jetzt eingeführt haben geht das doch
ganz einfach begleiten das jetzt hier
rein
so darf sich ruhig umdrehen und jetzt
ganz großen papier definitiv raus gehen
genau und wie lange das kommt immer
darauf an wie heißes fett ist ich schaue
ich mal auf die uhr dann wenden wir euch
das am besten ein und gute idee
[Musik]
das sind unsere sprits kuchen und ich
weiß dass die so schon total
verführerisch sind und man am liebsten
reinbeißen würde aber zu einem
spritztouren gehört immer noch so einen
guss und das ist jetzt kein bus aus
puderzucker und zitronensaft sondern ein
gruß aus cola zucker und diesmal milch
und da gebe ich jetzt einfach so viel
milch zum puderzucker
bis es so eine schöne masse gibt darf
nicht zu flüssig sein
[Musik]
und jetzt ganz ganz stark bleiben
der kurs muss nämlich noch antrocknen
für den liebsten jetzt schon essen aber
ich darf nicht jammern
ich muss jetzt erstmal auch mittagessen
unser gemüse steht schon bereit krassen
gegensatz ne richtig süß und frittiert
und dann machen wir gleich was mit
gemüse aber das finden wir ja auch zum
glück also ihr werdet auf jeden fall
wissen was es sein wird und euch jetzt
ganz ganz ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen
das gute ist immer bei solchen rezepten
ihr wisst einfach lecker spitz kuchen
ist das ist jetzt nicht komplett neu
ausgedacht sondern das gibt es schon und
es kennt ihr vom bäcker und die
schmecken mindestens genauso gut wenn
ich um ehrlich zu sein sogar noch besser
wird es gemacht wie immer muss immer
genau und jetzt einmal in die infobox
schon für die genauen mengenangaben auf
jeden fall ein bäumchen nach oben da
lassen die bisherigen geschaut haben und
dann freue ich mich wenn ihr im nächsten
rezept auch wieder mit dabei sein
[Musik]